if I go into the car garage right you
have to make a decision what you truly
want in your life if you truly want to
just find a manager and look after you
and take care of you you're going to be
his Queen he's going to be loyal you can
find that all day but you're going to
have to settle to a degree where a lot
of women perhaps are not prepared to do
that you see the you see how women act
they'd rather chase a fraction of a real
G's time than have a hundred percent of
the time of a [ __ ] dude who they
don't they don't respect at that level
and it's kind of like going to a car
dealership you walk in there you if you
want reliability you can get in this
sand but if you want to get a Ferrari it
comes with it comes with headaches it's
going to come a problem so when girls
say to me oh you know what Andrew you
know you should be loyal to it men like
me don't have to be and you know that so
why the [ __ ] are you here trying to tell
me what to do because you know I don't
have to be loyal and all the girls I'm
[ __ ] don't have to be loyal so why
are you sitting here pretending you
expected me to be loyal when everyone
knew from ground up day one it was never
going to ever [ __ ] happen and you're
still here I think you're still texting